[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba ben Melo İsmailoğlu
Diken voleybolcuyum
Bosna
çok küçük bir şehirde doğdum ve 16
yaşıma kadar yaşadım
babam aile firmasının yönetiyor ama en
büyük hayatının en büyük Tutkusu her
zaman basketbolda
küçükken babama basketbol oynarken
izlerdim maçlarına giderdim ve onun
hayatının en büyük Tutkusu bir oyun
olması bana çok cazip geliyordu
Babamla beraber voleybol maçlarını da
sık sık takip ediyorduk Türkiye'de ne
kadar başarılı voleybol varmış derdik
Olimpiyatları izlerdik izlerken Gözlerin
parlardı
sporda Zirve olimpiyata gitmektir daha
ötesi yok inanılmaz bir gurur ama biz
küçük fakir bir ülkede yaşadığımız için
oraya gitmenin sadece hayalini
kurabiliyorduk
babam gibi
büyük maçlarda büyük mücadeleleri ve
oyun insanlara göstermek isterdim 8
yaşında voleybola başladım Okulda da
başarılıydım ama 14 yaşıma geldiğim
zaman bu ev bolluğu da çok başarılı
olduğumu tespit edildi ve yurt dışına da
gitme fırsatım oldu
ailem resmen bir bahis oynadı 16 yaşında
beni Türkiye'ye yolladılar Ankara'da il
Bank kulübüne gittim ve bizim Bosna'da
yarısını bile görmediğimiz ilgi imkanlar
ve şartlarıyla büyülendik
Üstelik ev yemek dil kursu aylık harçlık
ve vatandaşlık konularda da çok yardımcı
oldular
küçük ve fakir bir ülkenin ailesinden
bir oyun için küçük yaşta ailesinden
ayrılan Nadir çocuklardandım
aileme akıl vermeye çalışan insan çok
oldu Bunu neden yaptığınız daha çok
küçük o kadar uzaklara kendi başına
gönderilir mi okul doğru düzgün bitirmez
sırf Top Oynasın diye bu yapılır mı akla
gelebilecek en kötü senaryoları örnek
vererek ne kadar yanlış bir karar
olduğunu anlatmaya çalıştılar
o şekilde büyüdü ve başka hiç kimse
farklı bir şey deneyemez diye
düşünüyorlardı
Annem ve babam çok açık görüşlü
oldukları için kendimi çok şanslı
hissediyorum ve iyi ki Bence düşünmeyip
benim geleceğim için daha iyi bir
geleceğim için öyle büyük bir karar
verdiler
bizim çocuğumuz bir oyun için bizden
ayrılıyor olabilir dediler ama hayatının
değiştirebilecek ve büyük kapıları
açacak bir oyun
Herkesin fikrine saygı duydular ama
biliyorlardı ki çocuk başarısız olursa
en kötü evine ülkesine geri dönerdi Ama
başarılı olursa çok büyük bir fırsatı
yakalamış olur ve kimseyi dinlemeden o
kararın arkasında durdular
yılda bir görüşürdük ama her akşam
saatlerce Görüntülü konuşarak sanki
benimle beraber evde kalıyorlarmış
gibiydi her zaman destek verdiler ve
arkamda durdular tabi Hikaye ne kadar
güzelse bir o kadar da üzücü ve zor
tarafı da vardır
ilk senede ağladım evimi ailemi
arkadaşlarımı ne kadar çok özlediğimi
fark ettim
yaşıtlarımın arasında en yeteneklerden
biri omama rağmen Türkiye'de hemen ön
plana çıkamadım
takım arkadaşlarıma göre daha güçsüz bu
ev bana anlamında daha az ilgili ve
ayrıca dil sorunu ile uğraşıyordum
ilk defa tek başıma evde yaşıyordum
çamaşır yıkayıp
yemek yapmam gerekiyordu psikolojik
olarak en Ergen dönemimde çok büyük bir
şey başarmaya çalıştım
kendimi bildiğim bilelim mükemmeliyetçi
biriyim eğer bir işe başladıysam
Başarılı bir şekilde bitirene kadar
durmazdım
ailem bana hiçbir baskı yapmadan ben
kendimi çok büyük bir baskı oluşturdum
günlerim psikolojik olarak zor geçiyordu
Türkçem az olduğu için okula gidip
dersleri dinlerken hiçbir şey anlamadan
eve geri dönerdim
takım arkadaşlarım İngilizce de çok iyi
bilmiyordu benimle çok iletişime
geçmiyorlardı
kendimi çok yükleniyordum ve
antrenmanlarda mesela Hoca kızdığı
zamanlarda da bile kendime çok
yükleniyordum
Sürekli hata yapan biri olarak kendimi
görürdüm 18 yaşında takımına da
çalışmaya başladım ve takımın en küçüğü
olarak doğal olarak daha fazla hata
yapıyordum ve göze batıyordum
antrenmanın akışını bozuyormuşum gibi
hissediyordum bunlar bana çok büyük bir
baskı oluştururdu ve büyüklerin yanında
kendimi hep daha iyi göstermek istedim
her akşam eve geldiğimde üzülsem de
ailemi anlatmazdım onlar üzülmesin diye
zaten benden uzaklar diye üzüldüklerini
biliyordum
şimdi küçükken bu tarz Dertler Bana çok
büyük geliyordu ailemi bırakıp farklı
ülkeye geldim Onlar benim için
fedakarlık yaptı Ben de onlar için
savaşacağım derken Hep Kendimi
büyüklerin arasında en yeteneksiz olarak
hissettim
18 yaşıma geldiğimde
vatandaşlık evraklarım daha yeni elime
ulaştı ve yaşımda oldu diye beni altyapı
bir takıma yeteneklerimi test etmeye
bile davet edemediler
altyapıda milli takımda Kendimi
göstermezsem nasıl daha büyük başarılar
elde ederim diye çok kaygılandım 2 yıl
geçti ama hala geleceği ile alakalı
belirsizlik vardı Acaba hatamı yaptım
başka bir ülkeye gidip iyi bir okul mu
bitirmem gerekiyordu diye
endişeleniyordum
Belki benim geleceğim sporcu olmak
değildir
tabi yine bu düşüncelere ailemle
paylaşmıyordum onlar üzülmesin diye
bugün bunlar aklıma geldikçe ne kadar
salakça hareket ettiğimi anlayabiliyorum
ailem o kadar anlayışlı ki Muhtemelen
dertlerimi dinleyip o süreci daha kolay
atmamı sağlardı
Psikolojik destek Özellikle o ergen
döneminde o kadar önemli ki hayatı
kolaylaştıran en önemli şey olduğunu
düşünüyorum
voleybol liglere kışın oynanır oyuncular
da yazın milli takıma gider ve full yazı
milli takıma geçirir
Ben yazıları Normalde Bosna'ya giderdim
ve plaj voleybol Oynardım hem voleybola
çok para vermemiş olurdum hem
arkadaşlarımla eğlenceli zaman geçirdim
bu sefer Türkiye'de kalmayı tercih ettim
ve plaj voleybol oynamaya karar verdim
profesyonel turnuva düzenlendiğini
duydum ve katılmaya karar verdim
sonra adam bir gün önce şans eseri
yabancı bir ama tecrübeli bir oyuncu ile
tanıştım ve o turnuvaya beraber katıldık
16 takımdan 3 olduk
üçüncülük maçında Türkiye'nin en
tecrübeli ve en başarılı takımını yendik
inanılmaz mutlu oldum sonunda işler iyi
yönde gittiğini hissettim
o turnuvadan sonra beni plaj voleyboluna
milli takımına Davet ettiler
inanılmaz gurur duydum En azından sezon
arası yazların boş geçmeyecekti ve kumda
çok daha iyi antrenman yaparak
güçleneceğini biliyordum
Öyle de oldu 2 yaz üst üste
oynayınca takıma döndüğüm zaman daha
hızlı daha çok sıçrayan daha güçlü ve
daha akıllı oynayan bir oyuncu olarak
döndüm
Aa takımda oynama fırsatım çıktı ve çok
iyi değerlendirerek sezon sonu 2014'te
veya Bahçeden teklif ve salon A milli
takımından davet aldım
20 yaşında O Benim Hayatım dönüm noktası
oldu
tabi yine takımında da seviye çok daha
yüksek ve ben yine takımın en küçüğüyüm
yine en yeteneklilerin arasında Kendime
yer bulmaya çalışan bir çocuktum
Ama bu sefer Mental olarak daha güçlü ve
daha kararlıydım
milli takım benim adıma çok başarılı
geçti O Yaz dünya çapında en güçlü
rakipleri yenerek Ben de oynama
fırsatımın çok iyi değerlendirdim
Artık yeni genç yetenek olarak
biliniyordum ve çok fazla ilgi görmeye
başladım bu beni çalışmaya ve kendimi
geliştirmeye daha da çok motive etti ve
en üst seviyede Kendime yer bulmuşken
mümkün olduğunca orada kalmak istedim
ailem benimle çok gurur duyuyordu ve her
maçımı tekrar tekrar izledim Hiç
Gitmesin diyen insanlar artık ailemi
arayıp tebrik etmeye başladılar
ve aslında ne kadar doğru karar
verdiklerini anlatmaya başladılar
2014'te başlayıp çok başarılı 3 sene
Fenerbahçe'de 2 sene eczacıbaşı'nda İki
sene Vakıfbank'ta oynadım ve şimdi
Fenerbahçe'de ikinci dönemimdeyim Yani
toplamda 5 sezonumu geçiriyorum
milli takımda tecrübeli Ablalarımız
bıraktığından beri yerlerini en iyi
şekilde ben ve yaşıtlarım doldurmaya
çalışıyoruz ve en büyük hayalimize
olimpiyata giderek gerçekleştirdik
15 bin nüfusu olan küçük bir şehirde
Doğan biri olarak
Olimpiyatı sadece televizyonda
izleyebileceğimi düşünüp
gerçekten olimpiyatlara gidebilmek paha
biçilemez bir başarı oldu benim için
ailemin ve arkadaşlarımın gururu
kelimelere dökülemez
Benim arkamdaki güç
başarılarımın mimarları Aslında onlar
benim hayatımdaki şansım
ailemin çok açık görüşlü olmasıydı
onların vizyonu olmadan belki ben bugün
burada olmazdım
onlar belki benim için sadece ilk adımı
attı ama sonrasında onlardan aldığım
ilham ve gördüğüm fedakarlılığın uğruna
çok savaştım
bir an bile pes etmeyi düşünmedim son 13
yılda birçok başarıya ulaştım ama tabi
kaybettiğim zamanlarda çok oldu her
kaybımda çok üzüldüm ama büyük bir ders
olarak kullandım Ve beni bir adım geriye
değil de kendimi hangi konularda hala
eksik olduğunu ve geliştirmem
gerektiğini anlamak için kullandım
Çünkü oyun hala devam ediyor başarılı
olmadan tatmin olmayacağını biliyordum
Belki sizin de aynı şekilde aileniz
vardır ya da yoktur ama
kendi hayatınızın veya çocuğunuzun
hayatının gidişatını siz
belirleyebilirsiniz
bana bu oyunun başarının sırrı nedir
diye sorsanız kapalı kutuna dışında
dermek
düşünmek derdim
ileriyi öngörebilmek ama oraya ulaşmak
için sabırlı ve emin adımlarla ilerlemek
benim ailemi diğer insanlardan farklı
gösteren şey
Başkaların aklına gelmeyen çözümler ve
fikirler bizi hayatının hazırladığı
oyuna ileriye götüren şey olur
geleceği diğer insanların mümkün
Olduğunu hayal edemediği şekilde
görebilmek
Herkesin onayladığı şekilde ve diğer
insanların onlara koyduğu kurallara
uymayarak başarıya ulaşabilmek için
riske girmek bu rekabetli dünyada Hayat
denilen oyunda öne geçmek demektir
bu oyunu oynayan Sizsiniz kuralları
belirleyen Siz olursanız kimse size
engel olamaz ve başarılı olursunuz
teşekkürler
[Alkış]